[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHANTAL BERMAN: My research
is about how states respond to social protest
movements in contemporary North Africa.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHANTAL BERMAN: This is the first protest
that I attended in Morocco.
This is a protest of teacher trainees.
So they're these people.
You can see, they're wearing their white coats.
And they are protesting against these privatization
measures that have been moving forward in
Morocco and the education system.
People have come from all over the country
to protest in the capital.
Morocco, as of right now, is not a political
democracy.
But nonetheless, people are able to organize
and to actually affect policy in line with
their interests, by doing these big marches
in the symbolic space of the capital area
and the parliamentary area.
AMANEY JAMAL: She took it upon herself to
design one of the most comprehensive event
data sets of protest movements and protest
activity in the five years before the Arab
Spring in two countries, Morocco and Tunisia.
And in the five years after the Arab Spring
in both countries, as well.
CHANTAL BERMAN: So we really have to do a
lot of our own data collection.
So I've started a process where I have a great
team of RAs who are working with me to source
event data from local newspapers, all of which
are in paper copy, not digitized, out of these
local libraries and archives.
It's exciting to be able to turn something
that sort of non-digitized and sort of rotting
away somewhere in an archive basement, into
a resource that hopefully I, and other scholars,
can use to learn more about mobilization.
And learn more about tactics and strategies
that activists can use to achieve their rights.
AMANEY JAMAL: She's out there.
She's in the protests.
She's watching what's happening.
She's listening to their demands.
She's listening to their slogans in ways that
is just remarkable for a young researcher.
CHANTAL BERMAN: I am super glad that I came
to Princeton.
And I think the number one reason is my advisers
and my faculty.
My advisers are incredible intellectuals,
and they're also fantastic mentors.
And they've been really, I think, generous
with me, in terms of supporting this somewhat
kind of crazy sounding project and have also
been really giving of their time to sort of
nurture young scholars.
And that's really inspiring for me, as, hopefully,
a future professor.
[MUSIC PLAYING]